smith the alley-oop to bradley beal
to go but a highlight play already the
backdoor alley-oo
bradley beal with a finish three-point
lead troy brown will inbound
gets it to bryant to beale
second straight quarter a buzzer beater
for the wizards
practices the deflection feel
oh yeah it's good he's got 20. to get
the shooters when you're playing his own
feel for three that's good bradley beals
got 12 and the wizards back on
there's a good defensive play rotation
by the wizards the turnover
defense but bradley bill
getting out in front of the races for
the throwdown
[Applause]
field one second left has to put the
shot
up and he gets the roll
what do you think is there a foul yes
that's a foul
[Music]
see what happens off the miss spiel the
other way
gets a bump by heartless got it and the
foul time and time again for
bradley beals
field step back difficult eagle puts it
in
what a shot there by bradley bela's got
nine first quarter points
neal has it with six seconds
field gets in the paint puts it up and
in
in the queen city there's a story on the
my team's app right now how steven
strasberg just signed the deal as
bradley beal throws down the dunk
guess what it's this by bradley beal
little
old-fashioned give-and-go bradley kicked
in good pass from wagner look where he
takes off from
on their feet here at the capital one
arena
berton stabile five seconds spiel
crossover
in the paint step back for the win got
it
five tenths of a second remaining
credit the bulls doing a good job not
letting brad get it
on the first round but great job by brad
on the step back
to focus locking in that window
having enough time and patience
to complete the game and miss shots
especially from the deep corners we
talked about missing that shot it's
probably
like a turnover oh nice back door cut by
davis burton for the dunk
deal we'll go all the way to the hoop
three seconds field lost it puts the
shot up
in time got it
bradley beal think about last night how
the team started think about tonight
you're down by seven against
philadelphia on the road
and they're over eight from three-point
left 1884 to welcome in
the new draft class so jan really spoke
highly about that i even talked to
antoine jameson about it
who works in the wizards front office
feels so dangerous spins stops pops
off the glass and then this guy's really
good you haven't seen bradley field play
i know he's in the knees
i mean they're getting to the spots they
want to offensively and now
a chance for a four-point play as beal
knocks down the three
drumming on him shot clock down to four
here's beal
beal step back for three the entire
bench is up there
we talk about mortal kombat sub zero
he's have a move get over here
bradley bill look at the bench
neal splits the double team for the
two-headed dunk
wow bradley beal looking at tonight's
honda drive of the game
bradley bill after that split to the
dunk
[Applause]
here's beale trying to get to the basket
with the dunk
and the first lead of the game for the
wizards quarter
attacking the hoop with authority 76.75
wizards he's got 28. let's got 22.
bledsoe tries to jump into bryant gets
it back from the give-and-go
tip ball here's bryant with the steal up
ahead to beale
beale one hand a dunk over
lopez and now a technical foul
that's my mindset jay take it right to
the basketball steal the league's best
three-point shooter
missus
thomas the lob to feel bradley beal
throws down the alley-oop and he's got
38. joe harris a three-point shooter
gotta watch out for him now he goes to
the hoop has it blocked by beal off of
harris
good defensive play for bradley beale
troy brown jr finding b opia puts it up
and in
and the wizards take the lead there is
still time on the clock
brown jr the cut by beal in the stream
by mo
wagner and the pass and hold on
coach brooks great play great play item
is running down doesn't mean you shoot a
step back
field splits pulls up hits the jumper
at the horn 16 in the first half for
beale and they put the lead back up to
seven wizards one here on december 23rd
121-115 neal lost it now he gets it back
the lob to bonga off the backboard
[Applause]
shot clock at three field with the left
beautiful move by bradley beal
10 points for beale
[Applause]
no it's not sunday but andre drummond
just got baptized
let me check this out
wow and he's he's letting you know right
there he's got the crowd chris middleton
making beat you off the dribble
from the top for three steven schenzel
has it stripped napier looking up ahead
to beale
[Applause]
bledsoe tries to find ilyasova turns it
over three on one
it's beal to the hoop again
[Applause]
this is happening on a nightly
now basis four on the shot clock field
goes baseline
field gets it off in time and puts it in
nifty move by bradley beal washington
area honda dealers
it was this move by beal wow i mean
that's just
cat walk to catwalk
field oh big pick set by brian jones
went down
beale hits the three and i gotta wonder
is jones okay